for that false claim the Washington Post
fact checker
ordered my colleague three nokia another
colleague claimed judge Cavanaugh
described contraceptives as abortion
inducing drugs the video that my
colleague shared on the Internet
was doctored to omit the fact that judge
Cavanaugh was describing the plaintiffs
claims in a case that he decided not his
own views my colleague was ordered four
Pinocchios and now of course that's the
most Pinocchio's you can get but they
still had one big card to play which
they had kept away up their sleeves for
a month actually for 45 days I think by
July the ranking member received a
letter from dr. Christine Blasi Ford
alleging that judge Kavanagh sexually
assaulted salted her in high school 36
years ago instead of referring dr. Ford
to the FBI or sharing these allegations
with her colleagues either of which
would have respected and preserved
dr. Ford's confidentiality and that's
what dr. Ford requested the ranking
member referred dr. Ford to democratic
activist attorneys closely tied to the
Clintons the ranking members Shefford
shamefully sat on these allegations for
nearly seven weeks only to reveal them
at the eleventh hour when it appeared
judge Cavanaugh was headed for towards
confirmation because he was sole so
qualified the ranking member had
numerous opportunities to raise these
allegations with judge Kavanagh
personally I'll give you six examples
she could have discussed them with judge
Cavanaugh during their private meeting
on August the 20th a meeting which took
place after her staff had sent dr. four
to democratic lawyers or another time
shared them with 64 of her Senate
colleagues who also met with him
individually the ranking members staff
could have raised them with judge
Cavanaugh during a background
investigation follow-up call in late
August senators could have asked judge
Cavanaugh about the allegations during
his 32 hours of testimony over the
course of three days judiciary members
could have asked judge Kavanagh about
this in their closed session of the
hearing which the ranking member didn't
attend the closed session is the
appropriate place to bring up issues
where confidentiality is supposed to be
respected and there were no questions
about these allegations
among the 1,300 written questions sent
to judge Cavanaugh after the hearing
this amounts to more than more written
questions submitted to this nominee
after a hearing than to all Supreme
Court nominees combined keeping the July
30th letter secret deprived senators of
having all the facts that they needed to
have about this nomination so it wasn't
then until September 13th July 32
September 13th nearly seven weeks after
the ranking member received these
allegations and on the eve of the
confirmation vote that the ranking
member
referred them to the FBI and somehow
they were leaked to the press
it wasn't until those news reports on
September 16th that I learned even of
dr. Ford's identity this is an outrage
the political motives behind the
Democrats actions should be obvious to
everyone dr. Ford requested the
opportunity to tell her story to the
Senate Judiciary Committee after a lot
of foot-dragging by dr. Ford's attorneys
they finally agreed to a public hearing
promised I provided a safe comfortable
and dignified forum for dr. Ford as well
as judge Cavanaugh dr. Ford was sincere
in her testimonies as with Judge
Cavanaugh who emphatically denied the
allegations it's true that confirmation
hearings on the trial but trials have
rules based on common sense notions of
fairness and due process not the other
way around it's a fundamental aspect of
fairness a fundamental aspect of due
process that the accuser have the burden
of proving allegations judge Cavanaugh
was publicly accused of a crime and his
reputation and livelihood were at stake
so it was only fair that his accuser
have the burden of proof the consensus
is that the burden was not met
ultimately the existing evidence
including the statements of three
alleged eyewitnesses named by dr. Ford
refuted dr. Ford's version of the facts
our investigative nominee nation consul
Rachel Mitchell who has nearly 25 years
of experience advocating for sexual
assault victim and investigating sex
crimes concluded that there was lack of
specificity and simply too many
inconsistencies in dr. Ford's allegation
to establish that Judge Cavanaugh
committed sexual assault even under the
lowest standard approved she concluded
quote he said she said case is
incredibly difficult to prove but this
case is even weaker than that dr. Ford
identified other witnesses to the events
and those witnesses either refuted her
allegation or failed to reach
corroborate them for the reasons
discussed below I do not think that a
reasonable prosecutor could bring this
case based upon the evidence before the
committee nor do I believe that this
evidence is sufficient to satisfy the
preponderance of evidence standard end
of quote so we have thoroughly
investigated judge
background in addition to the prior six
FBI full field field background
investigations with the interviews of
nearly a hundred and fifty people who
have known judge Cavanaugh his entire
life the committee also separately and
thoroughly investigated every credible
allegation that we received our more
than 20 committee staff members have
worked night and day over the last many
weeks tracking down virtually all leads
and at the request of undecided members
the FBI reopened judge Cavanaugh his
background investigation for another
week
the FBI interviewed ten more people
related to the latest credible sexual
assault allegations and the FBI
confirmed what we Senate investigators
already concluded that is this there's
nothing in the Supplemental FBI
background investigation report that we
didn't already know these uncorroborated
accusations have been unequivocally and
repeatedly rejected by Judge Kavanaugh
and neither the Judiciary Committee nor
the FBI could locate any third parties
who can attest to any of the allegations
there also is no contemporary
contemporaneous evidence this
investigation found no hint of
misconduct and the same is true of six
prior FBI investigations conducted
during Judge Cavanaugh's twenty-five
years of public service nothing an
investigator including career FBI
Special Agents does ever be good enough
to satisfy Democrat leadership sin
Washington who staked out opposition to
judge Kavanaugh before he was even
nominated there is simply no reason then
to the deny judge Kavanaugh a seat on
the Supreme Court on the basis of the
evidence presented to us the Democratic
strategy used against judge Kavanaugh
has made one thing clear they will never
be satisfied no matter how fair and
thorough the process is
31 years ago the Senate Democrats
treatment is Robert Bork their playbook
remains the same for the left-wing
advice and consent has become
search-and-destroy
a demolition derby I'm pleased to
support judge Cavanaugh's confirmation
I'm sorry for what the whole family went
through the last several weeks we should
all admire Cavanaugh's willingness to
serve his country despite the way he's
been treated it would be a travesty then
if the Senate did not confirm the most
qualified nomination in our nation's
history the multitude of allegations
against him have proven to be false
they've also proven that no discussion
of his qualifications came up with any
discussion of his qualifications nothing
showed he wasn't qualified we had a
campaign of distraction from his
outstanding qualifications a campaign of
destruction of this fine individual what
we have learned is the resistance that
has existed since the day after the
November 16 2016 election is centered
right here on Capitol Hill they have
encouraged mob rule when you hear things
about get in their face bother people at
every restaurant where you can find a
cabinet member these are coming from
public service that are a setting
example of civility in American society
and it's been made worse by what has
happened to judge Cavanaugh I hope we
can say no to mob rule by voting to
confirm judge Cavanaugh I yield the
floor
Madam President senator from California
Madam President
yeah I understand that in the order I
have 15 minutes is that correct the
senator is recognized thank you very
much mr. president madam president this
has been my ninth Supreme Court
nomination hearing and I must say I've
never experienced anything like this
never before have we had a Supreme Court
nominee where over 90% of his record has
been hidden from the public and the
Senate never before have we had a
nominee displays such flagrant
partisanship and open hostility at a
hearing and never before have we had a
nominee facing allegations of sexual
assault the nominee before us being
considered for a pivotal swing seat if
confirmed would be the deciding vote on
some of the most important and divisive
issues of our day I'd like to start by
speaking about some of the issues in
relationship to judge Kavanaugh
president Trump promised to only
nominate individuals to the Supreme
Court who would be pro-life and progam
overturn roe v wade in my judge judgment
judge Kavanagh clearly meets the test in
a speech in 2017 judge Cavanaugh focused
on praising justice Rehnquist and his
dissent in roe v wade where he
challenged the right to women's privacy
as protected in the Constitution also
last year judge Cavanaugh argued in a
dissent in a Texas case that a Jane Doe
should not be able to exercise her right
to choose because she did not have
family and friends help her make the
decision if adopted this argument could
rewrite Supreme Court precedent and
require courts to determine whether a
young woman had a sufficient support
network when making her
decision even in cases as is in this one
where she had gone before a court his
reasoning demonstrates the judge
Cavanaugh not only is willing to
disregard precedent but his opinions
fail to appreciate the challenging
realities women face when making these
most difficult decisions when I asked
him about whether Roe and Casey were
settled law and whether they were
correctly decided he refused to answer
he would only say these cases are
entitled to respect roe v wade as we all
know is one of a series of cases that
upheld an individual's right to decide
who to marry where to send your children
to school what kind of medical care you
can receive at the end of life as well
as whether and when to have a family the
government cannot interfere with these
decisions according to these cases
another issue that gives me great pause
is judge Cavanaugh's extreme view on
guns in reviewing his record and
judicial opinions it's clear his views
go well beyond simply being pro-gun
during a lecture at Notre Dame Law
School judge Kavanagh himself said he'd
be quote the first to acknowledge that
most lower court judges have disagreed
with his views on the Second Amendment
specifically in District of Columbia V
Heller judge Cavanaugh wrote in a
deciding dissenting opinion that unless
guns were regulated either at the time
of the Constitution was written or
traditionally throughout history they
cannot be regulated now end quote
in his own words gun laws are
unconstitutional unless they are quote
traditional or common in the United
States and quote judge Kavanagh would
have struck down DC's assault weapons
ban because they have not historically
been banned this logic means that as
weapons become more
and more dangerous they cannot be
regulated at all
when I asked judge Cavanaugh about his
views that if a gun is in common use it
cannot be regulated he replied this way
and I quote there are millions and
millions and millions of semi-automatic
rifles that are possessed so that seemed
to fit common use and not being a
dangerous and unusual weapon and quote
think about that Judge Cavanaugh made up
a new standard that had nothing to do
with common use but instead relied on
whether a gun is widely possessed and
owned as determinative as to whether it
is subject to any regulation the United
States makes up 4% of the worldwide
population but we own 42 percent of the
world's guns by judge cabin on standard
no state or locality will be able to
place any limitation on guns because of
widespread ownership in this country I'm
also concerned about his views on
presidential power specifically he has
said that sitting presidents cannot be
indicted cannot be prosecuted should not
be investigated and should have the
authority to fire a special counsel at
will in other words the President of the
United States is above and outside the
law these views raise serious concerns
that should concern us all especially at
a time when the president continually
threatens to fire the leadership of the
Department of Justice for failing to be
loyal and reining in the Muller
investigation these views alone are not
sufficient for me to vote against Judge
Cavanaugh but what we have seen and
experienced in the past several weeks
has raised serious new concerns concerns
I believe should worry as all judges are
expected to be quote even-handed
unbiased impartial and courteous
and quote however at the hearing last
week we saw a man filled with anger and
aggression judge Cavanaugh raised his
voice he interrupted senators he accused
of Democrats of quote lying in wait end
quote and replacing quote advice and
consent with Search and Destroy end
quote
he even went so far as to say that dr.
Ford's allegations were nothing more
than quote a calculated and orchestrated
political hit fueled with pent-up anger
about President Trump and the 2016
election end quote quote revenge on
behalf of the Clintons and close how
could he this behavior revealed a
hostility and belligerence that is
unbecoming of someone seeking to be
elevated to the United States Supreme
Court his display was so shocking that
more than 2,400 law professors from
around the country have expressed their
opposition they wrote and I quote
instead of trying to sort out with
reason and care the allegations that
were raised judge Cavanaugh responded in
an intemperate inflammatory and partial
manner as he interrupted and at times
was discourteous to senators and quote
the professor's concluded and I quote we
have differing views about other
qualifications of Judge Cavanaugh but we
are united as professors of law and
scholars of judicial institutions in
believing he did not display the
impartiality and judicial temperament
requisite to sit on the highest court of
our land Madam President I ask unanimous
consent to enter a full copy of the
letter in the record without objection
thank you
finally I want to mention the serious
and credible allegations raised by dr.
Christine Blasi Ford and Deborah Ramirez
the two women who came forward to tell
their experiences facing sexual assault
when dr. Ford decided to make her story
public she faced all her worst fears she
was harassed she received death threats
she had to relocate her home her husband
and two children and yet in less than a
week she came before the Senate and told
21 senators she had never met along with
millions of Americans about the most
tragic traumatic and difficult
experience of her life and she did so
with poise Grace and most importantly
bravery unfortunately she was met with
partisanship and hostility my Republican
colleagues have largely chosen to ignore
her powerful testimony senators weren't
allowed to hear from any witnesses who
could corroborate or refute her account
they refused to gather evidence or do an
impartial investigation into her
allegations Deborah Ramirez also
reluctantly came forward to tell her
story like dr. Ford miss Ramirez offered
to speak to the FBI both Ford and
Ramirez submitted evidence to support
their allegations including naming over
two dozen witnesses each unfortunately
the limited investigation that was
conducted by the FBI failed to interview
any one of the witnesses these two women
identified who could support her account
let me say that again they refused to
investigate to talk with any of the 24
witnesses that could have supported
their accounts
mr. president I think it's important to
remember why we're here today we're here
to determine whether judge Kavanaugh has
demonstrated the impartiality the
temperament the even-handedness that's
needed to serve on this great high court
of our land if confirmed he will join
eight other individuals who are charged
with deciding how the laws of our land
are interpreted and applied he would be
a deciding vote on the most important
issues affecting our country and every
American for generations to come
mr. president madam president based on
all the factors we have before us I do
not believe judge Kavanaugh has earned
this seat thank you
Madam President Democrat leader thank
you madam president
now madam president from start to finish
president Trump's nomination of Judge
Brett Kavanaugh to the United States
Supreme Court will go down as one of the
saddest most sordid chapters in the long
history of the federal judiciary the
well was poisoned from the outset when
president Trump's selected judge
Cavanaugh from a list of names
pre-approved by hard-right special
interest groups for whom the national
interest is a trifling concern compared
to repealing roe v wade cutting people's
health care and achieving a partisan
majority on the Supreme Court the rot
worsened when the Republican majority on
the Judiciary Committee shielded the
bulk of Judge Cavanaugh's records from
the public discarding decades of
bipartisan precedent and thwarting norms
of transparency and of fairness and
finally the dam broke under the weight
of credible allegations that Judge
Cavanaugh committed a sexual assault in
high school in 2018
the Republican majority conducted a
hearing that made the Anita Hill
hearings in 1991 look fair by comparison
in this hearing there were no
corroborating witnesses on either side
no independent investigation of the
facts to inform the questioning they
even hired an outside counsel to put a
witness dr. Ford on trial only at the
eleventh hour
urging of breakaway members of their
caucus Republicans submitted reluctantly
to a one-week investigation of the
allegations an investigation which was
then severely circumscribed by the White
House our Republican friends blame us
for this
they're always finding a strawman but
nothing could be further from the truth
first they blame us for delay knowing
full well that Majority Leader McConnell
has complete control of when nominees
are brought to the floor leader
McConnell could have moved this nominee
two weeks ago or one week ago Democrats
had nothing no say and don't when it
comes to who comes to the floor but in
each case
leader McConnell couldn't move the
nominee forward because he was blocked
by fellow Republicans not Democrats from
moving forward when it comes to
complaining about delay two words never
come from our Republican friends lips
Merrick garland Republicans are also
saying we engaged in quote a smear
campaign or the politics of personal
destruction with this nomination in
reality again they're using Democrats as
a straw man because what they're really
talking about is what dr. Ford said
Democrats did not induce her to come
forward her conscience did and our
Republican friends are our Republican
friends accusing dr. Ford and her deeply
held memories of what happened to her of
a smear campaign are they accusing dr.
Ford of a smear campaign of engaging in
the politics of personal destruction
because that is who they're actually
blaming they're decrying her testimony
and then trying to blame Democrats I
don't blame them they have a flawed
nominee they don't want the focus on the
nominee when future Americans look back
at these proceedings let them draw no
lessons from the Senate's conduct here
let them look back on this chapter as
the shameful culmination of the scorched
earth politics
practiced by the hard right in America
people who will stop at nothing to
entrench an advantage on our nation's
courts let the confirmation process for
judge Kavanaugh be recorded as a sorry
epilogue to the brazen theft of Justice
Scalia's seat the ignominious end of
bipartisan cooperation and consultation
on the confirmation of Supreme Court
justices and for what for whom were
Senate Republican leaders willing to
discard all semblance of fairness to
confirm judge Brett Kavanaugh certainly
a product of an elite education but also
someone with hard right conservative
jurisprudence far far away from what
average Americans believe why most
Democrats opposed his nomination at the
outset feels like ancient history now
but let us not forget that most
importantly we strongly disagree with a
number of judge Cavanaugh's views he's
deeply skeptical of unenumerated rights
including a woman's right to make
fundamentally private decisions about
her medical care he's deeply skeptical
of the government's role in protecting
Americans with pre-existing conditions
he's deeply skeptical of nearly all
rules and regulations that protect
consumers workers the environment and
the flashing red light warning sign at
the center of Judge Cavanaugh's
jurisprudence are his views on executive
power and accountability somehow this
conservative judge and scholar of the
Constitution sees at the heart of
American democracy a president whom King
an executive whose unaccountable to the
laws he's sworn to uphold a head of
state who while in office
should be beyond the reach of subpoenas
criminal investigations or civil
investigations this moment in American
history demands deep skepticism about
judge Cavanaugh's views on executive
power nominated as he was by an
executive who disdains the constraints
of his office and who is at this very
moment the apparent subject of
investigations his Supreme Court nominee
believes should be invalid
I met with judge Kavanagh for almost two
hours and I asked him about all of those
issues his answers were constantly
evasive and utterly unsatisfactory it
was deja vu all over again in the first
round of hearings when Judge Cavanaugh
deliberately avoided talking about his
views on road healthcare presidential
accountability and more there was no
legal reason rule or logic that
prevented him from being clear and
saying what he thought he was evasive
because he knows that his views are
deeply at odds with the progress America
has made over the last century of
jurisprudence and at odds with what most
Americans believe his performance
trading to the Senate it was unfair to
the American people when a nominee
refuses to disclose their views chances
are you have a nominee whose views are
far outside the mainstream of America
whether they be far right or far left my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle may not have as grave a concern
about these views as we do but let no
American be surprised if judge Kavanagh
becomes a decisive vote to restrict the
rights and privileges of the American
people while stretching the bounds of
privilege for the current occupant of
the White House
judge Cavanaugh's nomination ultimately
does not only encompass questions of
ideology or credentials but questions of
character here again judge Cavanaugh
falls woefully short of what Americans
expect and deserve in a Supreme Court
justice he has repeatedly misled the
Senate about his involvement in some of
the most serious controversies of the
Bush administration including
warrantless wiretapping of American
citizens our policy against torture the
theft of electronic records from
Democratic senators and his involvement
in the nomination of very controversial
judges faced with credible allegations
of various types of misconduct judge
Cavanaugh's credibility was again tested
and he continued to dissemble and even
prevaricate about easily refuted facts
beyond the issue of credibility judge
Kavanagh presented to the Senate the
bitterest partisan testimony I have ever
heard coming from a candidate seeking
the Senate's approval whether they be
for the bench or the executive branch
now there are many who think that what
happened when Judge Cavanaugh was 17
years old should not be dispositive even
if you believe that his actions at age
53 in terms of demeanor partisanship and
above all credibility should be
dispositive judges at every level of the
federal bench should be held to the
highest standard of ethics and moral
character judges at every level should
be judicious and credible and
independent but especially especially on
the Supreme Court I do not see how it's
possible for my colleagues to say with
perfect confidence that judge Kavanagh
has the temperament independence and
credibility to serve on the United
States Supreme Court
so I asked my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle why Judge Cavanaugh
there is no dictate that you have to
march blindly forward with a nominee
when there are others available to you
there are many judges who I'm sure
conservatives would be happy to have on
the court I'd remind my colleagues the
seat that Brett Kavanaugh aspires to
fill was held by a Justice who assumed
the bench after one nominee was voted
down by the Senate and a second nominee
withdrew his nomination but the
Republican majority has pressed forward
blindly on judge Kavanagh
even when brave women came forward to
speak truth to power why for what cause
for the sake of winning that's not
reason enough my colleagues on the other
side if you have doubts about judge
Cavanaugh's credibility about his
ability to tell the truth about his
ability to be impartial in nonpartisan
no matter what you think of his
jurisprudence or what he may or may not
have done in high school in college you
should not vote to confirm him to the
Supreme Court
so my friends Democrat and Republican
for all the controversy all the heavy
handedness of the process all the
hyperbole and vilification of both sides
there's always hope that the Senate can
save itself we can salvage some decency
here at the end if judge Kavanagh is
rejected President Trump will select
another nominee likely right-of-center
probably not to my liking but without
the cloud that hangs over this nominee
and we can proceed to consider that
nominee in a much less bitter much
better less partisan way a bipartisan
majority of senators
considering fully the weight of judge
Cavanaugh's testimony record credibility
trustworthiness and temperament
considering fully the heartbreaking
testimony of dr. Christine Blasi Ford
can vote to reject judge Cavanaugh's
nomination and ask the President to send
the Senate another name for the sake of
the Senate of the Supreme Court and of
America I hope I pray my colleagues will
do so
Madam President the majority leader it
was 88 days ago that President Trump
announced his nomination of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh to fill the current vacancy on
the Supreme Court judge Cavanaugh is a
nominee of the very highest caliber a
brilliant legal mind an accomplished
jurist with a proven devotion to the
rule of law
today the Senate has the opportunity to
advance his nomination every one of us
will go on record with one of the most
consequential votes you ever cast in the
Senate now the stakes are always high
for a Supreme Court nomination but
colleagues the extraordinary events of
recent weeks have raised them even
higher this time when we vote later this
morning we will not only be deciding
whether to elevate a stunningly
well-qualified judge to our highest
court not anymore not after all this the
United States Senate will also be making
a statement whether the state that
partisan politics can override the
presumption of innocence or will
reaffirm that in the United States of
America everyone is innocent until
proven guilty will either state that
facts and evidence can simply be brushed
aside when politically inconvenient and
signal that media bullying and mob
intimidation are valid tactics for
shaping the Senate the mob can attack
and the Senate case all will stand up
and say that serious thoughtful
fact-based deliberation will still
define this body
willing to give notice that totally
uncorroborated allegations are now
officially officially enough to destroy
an American's life or will declare that
our society cannot must not will not set
the bar so low so Madam President today
is a pivotal day in the nomination
process of this excellent judge but it's
a pivotal day for us here in the Senate
as well the ideals of Justice that have
served our nation so well for so long
are on full display
so let's step back and sample a few of
the choice moments that the Senate and
the American people have been treated to
during the disgraceful absolutely
disgraceful spectacle of the last two
weeks the very night Judge Cavanaugh was
announced as the president's choice we
heard the junior senator from Oregon
declare that this nominee would pave the
way to tyranny his audience crowds of
far-left protesters still filling in the
blanks on their picket signs they
weren't quite sure who the nominee was
going to be yet we've heard the junior
senator from New Jersey describe Judge
Cavanaugh's nomination as a great moral
struggle in which they're just two camps
you're either complicit and the evil or
you're fighting against it more recently
we've heard the junior senator from
Hawaii argue that her personal
disagreement with judge Kavanagh is
judicial philosophy meant now listen to
this
he deserved less of a presumption of
innocence when it came to allegations of
misconduct we disagree with her you're
not entitled to the presumption of
innocence when it comes to allegations
of misconduct that's what I'm a member
the Judiciary Committee that's the
definition of due process
apparently you get new process only if
you agree with her and even more
recently we saw the junior senator from
Rhode Island hold forth with great
confidence great confidence offering his
expert interpretations of goofy jokes in
high school yearbooks from the early
1980s that was incredibly enlightening
innocent jokes beer-drinking references
oh no our colleague was quite positive
there must be some other hidden or
sinister meanings at play until of
course a number of judge Kavanagh his
classmates set him straight
earlier this week so stop and consider
these snapshots the absurdity the
absurdity the indignity this is our
approach to confirming a Supreme Court
justice this is the Senate's
contribution to public discourse before
the ink has dried on Justice Kennedy's
retirement our Democratic colleagues
made it perfectly clear what this
process would be about delay obstruct
and resist and before the ink is dried
on judge Cavanaugh's nomination
colleagues across the aisle including
Democratic members of the Judiciary
Committee were racing to announce they
had made up their minds and we're
totally opposed to his confirmation mere
hours after Judge Kavanaugh was
nominated my friend the Democratic
leader promised quote I will oppose him
with everything I've got
he said hours after he was nominated it
was thus abundantly clear that his
number-one political goal was to defeat
the nomination by any means necessary it
was right there from the beginning Madam
President a clear declaration plain as
day nothing nothing could get most
Democrats to consider this nominee with
an open
it would be delaying tactics obstruction
and so-called resistance until the final
vote was called for a few weeks
their efforts played out of long lines
that sadly have become somewhat ordinary
around here
there were excuses for delay those fell
flat there were gross distortions of
Judge Cavanaugh's record that were
batted down by outside fact checkers and
there were all the usual phony
apocalyptic pronouncements that are
shouted whenever a Republican president
dares to nominate a Supreme Court
justice happened every time hostile to
women hostile to vulnerable people
hostile to workers same old tricks same
old playbook but here was the problem
the old plays weren't working the
distortions were being literally drowned
out by the facts
senators received and reviewed more
pages of background materials on Judge
Cavanaugh's nomination than for every
previous Supreme Court nomination
combined
we read judge Cavanaugh's 12-year record
of judicial rulings from our nation's
second highest court 300 plus opinions
we heard sworn testimony written
accounts from hundreds of character
witnesses from all stages of Judge
Cavanaugh's life and career and the
picture painted by these facts was
nothing like the caricature nothing like
the caricature so it's clear Madam
President the old tactics weren't
working but I'm gonna get the job done
the resistance demanded more try
something new they said well we all know
what happened next
uncorroborated allegations of the most
sensitive most serious sort were quickly
sharpened into political weapons one
such allegation shared by dr. Ford and
confidence with the
Democratic side of the Judiciary
Committee's somehow mysteriously found
its way into the press well chairman
Grassley immediately set out on a sober
focused search for the truth the
committee collected testimony organized
a new hearing and most recently asked
for the Supplemental FBI background
investigation judge Cavanaugh's 77th FBI
investigation by any fair standard the
facts the actual facts proved to be
straightforward no corroborating
evidence none naught was produced to
support any of the allegations leveled
against judge Kavanaugh no corroborating
evidence from the FBI inquiry or from
anywhere else nothing well that wasn't
enough for our Democratic colleagues of
course the facts were not exactly the
point after all we sort of get it by now
when the very FBI investigation for
which they've been clamoring turned up
no new evidence the Democrats move the
goalposts yet again I believe the latest
story is that the whole investigation is
invalid now listen to this because
individuals who had only recently been
told second hand or third hand about
nearly 40-year old allegations weren't
treated as essential witnesses let me
say that again the latest story is that
the whole investigation is invalid
because individuals who had only
recently been told second hand or third
hand about nearly 40-year old
allegations weren't treated as essential
witnesses nevermind and they didn't
actually witness anything they didn't
witness anything so let's be clear Madam
President these are not witnesses these
are people supposedly in possession of
hearsay that they first heard 35 years
after the suppose
fact what nonsense
the people whom dr. Ford claimed were
witnesses they have spoken with the FBI
we know that because today through their
attorneys put out public statements
saying so and what we know now is what
we knew at this time a week ago
there is absolutely no corroborating
evidence for these allegations same
thing we heard a week ago if they were
you bet we'd have heard about it
but there isn't so notwithstanding that
Madam President the leak of dr. Ford's
letter in violation of her privacy and
against her wishes opened the floodgates
the feeding frenzy was full on the
weaponization of her letter by the left
led to a torrent of other equally
uncorroborated allegations they were
dumped on judge Kavanagh and his family
and breathlessly breathlessly the media
seized on them the more outlandish the
better Americans were informed the judge
Kavanagh mastermind violent drug gangs
as a young teenager until that accuser
walked her story back we were informed
that judge Kavanaugh beat someone up on
a boat in a Rhode Island Harbor until
that accuser totally recanted we heard
another tall tale of physical assault
until that account was thoroughly
debunked by sitting federal judge oh and
yes we were informed that juvenile jokes
in his high school yearbook were
actually sinister secret references all
the Keystone Cops were on the case
Keystone Cops were on the case Madam
President and Senate Democrats cheered
them on they read parts of this
uncorroborated unbelievable mud
slide mud slide into the Senate record
they cited them an unofficial letter
demanding the judge Cavanaugh's
nomination be withdrawn were they true
well of course that was quite beside the
point quite beside the point so long as
they were convenient every effort was
made to ensure that the fact-free
verdict of the mob and the media would
win out over the actual evidence
make sure the mob prevails but the
uncorroborated mud and the partisan
noise and the physical intimidation of
members here in the Senate will not have
the final say around here the Senate
will have the final say-so Madam
President we're almost at the end of the
runway the cross rounds of anger and
fear and partisanship have blown strong
these past weeks they've harmed a good
man and his family
they've tarnished the dignity of this
institution but all of it can end today
the time has come to vote the Senate
stands on the threshold of a golden
opportunity we have the opportunity
advanced the nomination of an incredibly
well-qualified and well-respected jurist
to a post that demands such excellence
we have the opportunity to put judge
Brett Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court
where his distinguished service will
make us in our nation proud for years to
come but we have the opportunity to do
even more today we can send a message to
the American people that some core
principles remain unfettered by the
partisan passions of this moment facts
matter fairness Matt
the presumption of innocence is
sacrosanct the Senate has turned its
back on these things before Madam
President but never for long and never
without deep regret this institution
does not look proudly on the era of
Joseph McCarthy nor on any of the other
times when the politics of personal
destruction poisoned its judgment no no
the Senate looks back on those things
with shame and with the conviction that
we cannot go down that road again
we know the Senate is better than this
we know the nation deserves better than
this by confirming Judge Brett Kavanaugh
to the Supreme Court this brilliant
jurist will be charged with upholding
the rule of law and honoring American
justice we must hold ourselves to that
very same standard we must seize the
golden opportunity before us today to
confirm a Supreme Court justice who will
make us proud and to reaffirm our own
commitment to the Justice that every
single American deserves as a reminder
to our guests in the galleries
expressions of approval or disapproval
are not permitted in the Senate
galleries the clerk will report the
motion to invoke cloture cloture motion
we the undersigned Senators in
accordance with the provisions of rule
22 of the standing rules of the Senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of Brett M
Kavanagh to be an Associate Justice of
the Supreme Court of the United States
embassy Senators unanimous consent the
mandatory quorum call be waived is there
objection without an objection by
Unanimous Consent the mandatory quorum
call has been waived the question is is
it the sense of the Senate that debate
on the nomination of Brett M Kavanaugh
of Maryland to be an Associate Justice
of the Supreme Court shall be brought to
a close the yeas and nays are mandatory
under the rule the clerk will call the
roll mr. Alexander ms Baldwin
mr. Barroso mr. Bennett mr. Blumenthal
mr. blunt mr. Booker mr. Bozeman mr.
Brown mr. burr MS Cantwell mrs. capito
mr. Cardin mr. Carper mr. Casey mr.
Cassidy miss Collins mr. Coons mr.
corker mr. Cornyn miss Cortez Masto mr.
cotton mr. Crapo mr. Cruz mr. Danes
mr. Donnelly is duckworth mr. Durban mr.
Enzi mrs. Ernst mrs. Feinstein mrs.
fisher mr. flake mr. Gardiner mrs.
Gillibrand mr. Graham mr. Grassley MS
Harris miss Hassan mr. hatch mr.
Heinrich
his high camp mr. Heller miss her oh no
mr. Hoeven mrs. Hyde Smith mr. Inhofe
mr. Isaacson
mr. Johnson mr. Jones mr. Kane mr.
Kennedy
mr. King miss Klobuchar mr. Kyle
mr. Lankford mr. Lahey mr. Lee mr.
mansion mr. markey mrs. mccaskin mr.
McConnell mr. Menendez mr. Merkley mr.
Moran Ms Murkowski mr. Murphy
mrs. Marie mr. Nilsson mr. Paul mr.
Purdue mr. Peters
mr. Portman mr. Reid mr. rishe mr.
Roberts
mr. rounds mr. Rubio mr. Sanders
mr. sass mr. schat's mr. Schumer mr.
Scott
mrs. Shaheen mr. Shelby Miss Smith miss
Stabenow mr. Sullivan mr. tester mr.
Thoon mr. Tillis mr. Toomy mr. Udall mr.
Van Hollen mr. Warner MS Warren mr.
Whitehouse mr. wicker
mr. Wyden mr. young
senators voting in the affirmative
Alexander Barrasso blunt Bozeman burr
Caputo Cassidy Collins corker corn and
cotton Creepo Cruz Danes
in Z Ernst Fischer flake Gardner Graham
Grassley hatch Heller Hoeven hyde-smith
Inhofe Isakson Kennedy Kyle Lankford
McConnell Moran Paul Purdue Portman rich
Roberts rounds Rubio SAS Scott
Shelby Sullivan foon Tillis to me wicker
and young mr. mansion I senators voting
in the negative
Baldwin Bennett Booker brown Cantwell
Cardin Casey Coons Cortez Masto
Duckworth Durbin Feinstein Gillibrand
Harris Heinrich Cain Klobuchar Leahy
Markey Merkley Murkowski Murphy Murray
Nelson Peters shots Smith Stabenow
tester you dole Warner Warren White
House and widen
mr. Sanders no mr. Lee I miss Hassan No
mr. Jones No
mr. Johnson aye mr. Schumer No
mr. Donnelly no miss high-camp no mrs.
McCaskill no mr. Menendez No
mr. Reid No
mr. king No
mr. Van Hollen no
miss her oh no no
mr. Blumenthal no
mrs. Shaheen No
mr. Carper senator is not recorded I
thought no mr. Carper No
you
are there any Senators in the chamber
who wish to change their vote as a
reminder to our guests in the galleries
expressions of approval or disapproval
are not permitted in the Senate
galleries on this vote the yeas are 51
the noes are 49 the motion is agreed to